[موسيقى]
القنبله اليدويه هي السلاح طاغى على ساحات
القتال منذ الحرب العالميه الاولى كما كان
لها دور بارز في حسم الالاف من المواجهات
القريبه الاستخدام الاول للقنابل اليدويه
بدا في القرن الحادي عشر في الصين حينها
كان يعبا البارود في وعاء من السيراميك
مزود بفتيل ويقوم الجندي باشعاله والقائه
على الطرف الاخر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نجح البريطانيون في عام 1908 في تصنيع ما
يعرف بالقنبله اليدويه رقم واحد الا ان
هذه القنبله لم تكن امنه بشكل كاف على
الجندي المستخدم لها لكن في العام 1915
نجح المخترع البريطاني في صناعه اول قنبله
يدويه قريبه لشكلها الذي نعرفه الان
[موسيقى]
كان اشهر تصميم هو تصميما لقنبله المانيه
كانت تشبه شكل المطرقه لاحقا تم انتاج
قنابل يدويه حديثه متعدده المهام منها
قنابل مضاده للافراد واخرى مضاده للاليه
[موسيقى]